The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So I brought a few problems.
They're obviously not the quiz
problems, though some of them
are supposed to be similar.
What I have here
might not be what
you have on the quiz because
we might drop quiz problems
or because some of them
are just meant to make
you think and not to give away
the solutions to the quiz.
Now, before we get
started on this,
do you guys have any burning
questions or any concepts
that you want covered?
Based on that, I'll select
which problems we do.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This actually relates
not too much to the Pset.
If you're looking at
the time complexity
to maybe transfer something
from one table to another,
it takes a lot
more time, I would
assume, to move the actual
item to the new table
than it does just to look
at your point and be like,
oh, there's nothing there.
So if you were
just going to look
through an empty
table of size m,
the time to look through that
empty table, I'm assuming,
is much less than the time
to actually move an item.
PROFESSOR: So you're saying
we have m things here.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Some might
be nil, and some
might have stuff
in them, and you're
going to resize that to
presumably 2 times m,
and the way you
do that is you're
going to move the elements,
presumably by rehashing them,
right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: So these elements,
at least when we use Python,
we don't really store
big elements anywhere.
If you have a big
object, we always
work with references
to that object.
So you remember
the address where
that object lies in memory,
and since the memory is
finite and small, addresses are
all from 0 to a small number,
so they're constant.
So what you have here
is not a big object.
It's the address
of the big object,
so moving is always
constant time.
AUDIENCE: What I'm
saying is let's
say that the table
is completely full
versus completely empty table.
It would take more time
to move everything out
of the full table
than it does just
to look the empty table, right?
PROFESSOR: Let's see.
So writing something here
is order 1 time, right?
So moving is order 1 time.
Moving one element
is order 1 time.
What's accessing an element
in a table in a list?
You have a Python list.
What's the cost of
doing an index access?
AUDIENCE: It's also
order 1, right?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So order 1, index.
Order 1, move.
Suppose you have an empty table.
How many indices do you do?
How many times the index?
AUDIENCE: You look
at each one, so it's
order 1 times the
length of the table.
PROFESSOR: m.
So if the table is empty,
you have order m indices
and 0 moves.
Total running time, order m.
If you have a full
table, how many times
do you index in the table?
AUDIENCE: Still order m.
PROFESSOR: OK.
How many times do
you move stuff?
AUDIENCE: Order m.
PROFESSOR: Total running time?
AUDIENCE: It's order
2m, which is order m.
PROFESSOR: So it doesn't
matter whether the table's
full or empty.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Just wanted to confirm that.
PROFESSOR: And this
is how you do that.
Cool.
Thanks.
Any other questions?
Then we will go over problems in
the order in which I like them,
which is easiest to
hardest so that I
don't have to explain
the hard ones.
Warm up problem one.
So you have this recursion
and you have to solve it,
and you get a hint that n
to the power of 1 over log n
is 2, which is theta 1.
So based on the
hint, you can see
that it's going to
involve some math.
It's going to get a bit ugly.
So how do we solve recursions?
Two methods.
What are they?
AUDIENCE: Expand.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Substitution formally,
but basically, we
expand this guy
over and over again.
And?
AUDIENCE: Trees.
PROFESSOR: Recursion trees.
Which one do guys
want to do first?
If you only have
one t here, anything
works because you can keep
expanding it and that works,
so we can do either method.
Which one do you
guys want to go over?
Trees.
OK.
So we start with the first node.
The size of the problem is n.
What's the cost inside here?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this creates one sub-problem.
What's the size?
AUDIENCE: n to the 1/2.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Square root of n
equals n to the 1/2.
You solved it already.
What's the cost?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: Do people
remember this?
Is anyone confused about
what's going on here?
OK.
So two terms, something
involving t and something
not involving t.
The thing involving t is
what we want to get rid of.
When we do our recursion
tree, whatever is in here
goes inside here,
and this tells me
how this number
relates to this number.
So when I go from one
level to the next level,
this is the transformation.
n and becomes square root of
n, so the transformation here
is the same as the
transformation here.
What's next?
AUDIENCE: n to the 1/4.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Cost?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Do we need to do one more or
do people see the pattern?
Silence means one more.
If you guys don't speak,
we're going to go slow.
What's here?
AUDIENCE: n to the 1/8.
PROFESSOR: What's here?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: Let's hope
everyone saw the pattern,
and suppose we've done
this for l levels,
so we're at the bottom.
What should the cost
be at the bottom?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
We don't start with the cost.
What should the size of the
problem be at the bottom?
AUDIENCE: n to the
1 over 2 to the i.
PROFESSOR: Let's
say that this is
level h, where h is
the height of the tree.
AUDIENCE: Don't you want to
do something like n to the 1
over n?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK, so we want something
that looks like that?
AUDIENCE: If the recursion
tree is height i,
it is n to the 1 over 2
to the i, but 2 to the i
should equal n, or
approximately n.
PROFESSOR: Why?
I like that, but why?
AUDIENCE: Because
you need to go down
until you're only
looking at one element,
and that would be one
nth of the problem.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we want this guy
to look like what?
In fact, it doesn't exactly
have to look like 1, but what's
the advantage if we manage to
get this guy to look like 1?
We have a recursion.
We don't have a base
case here, right?
A reasonable base case
is T of 1 is theta 1.
Whatever function that is,
if you evaluate it at 1,
you're going to get a
constant, so you can say that.
Now, at the same time I can
say that for any constant,
c, T of c is theta 1.
So if I take this constant
here, which happens to be 2,
but that's not to
worry about that.
If I take this guy here,
I can put it in here.
And I know that this guy
here equals this guy here.
So if I can make this guy
here look like this guy here,
then I'm done.
Make sense?
If it makes sense,
everyone should nod so
that I know and I can go
forward, or smile or something.
So this should look like 1.
This is order 1 if not 1.
Let's make it order 1,
because it's 2 in this case.
What's the cost here?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
Everything inside the
bubbles is order of already,
so I don't need to
write an order of.
What do we do next?
AUDIENCE: Solve the
[INAUDIBLE] equation.
2 to the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You're
skipping one step.
That's exactly what you do
when you have the substitution
method.
You're going to get
to something and you
need to solve the equation.
But for the tree,
there are two steps.
So we need to add up
all the costs here
and that's the total cost here.
In order to do that, first,
we sum up over each level.
And in this case,
it's really simple
because there's only
one node per level,
but if you have multiple
nodes per level,
you have to sum
up for each level,
and then you have
to do a big sum.
What's the sum for this level?
1.
Come on, guys.
You're scaring me.
AUDIENCE: 1.
AUDIENCE: It's all 1.
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
So the only thing
that I'm missing
is to know how many levels I
have, because the sum is going
to be order h, whatever h is.
How do we do that?
n to the 1 over 2
to the power of h
has to equal this guy, right?
AUDIENCE: Why would
it equal that guy?
We know it's less
than that guy, but we
don't know it's
equal to that guy.
PROFESSOR: We have to make
it equal because we can only
stop when we get
to the base case.
So we have to expand
the recursion tree
until we get to a base
case, and then we stop,
and this is our base
case because this
is what the problem says
should be our base case.
AUDIENCE: Right, but n
to the 1 over 2 to the h
is not equal to n
to the 1 over log n.
PROFESSOR: Well, we can set
h to be whatever we want.
h is the height of the tree,
so we don't know what it is.
We have to find out what it is.
AUDIENCE: So let's
say 2 to the h
is equal to log n if you want
to make it look like that.
PROFESSOR: Let me
write down the equation
to make sure you're right.
You're probably right because
you're thinking faster than me,
but let me not embarrass myself
and do this the right way.
So you said 2 to the
h is log n, right?
Looks about right.
So what's h?
AUDIENCE: Log base 2.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Log log n.
So T of n is order h.
We got this from here.
T of n is order h is
order of log log n.
Math people drowning, right?
Any questions about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The first
line on the right--
PROFESSOR: This?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is that your base case?
What is that?
PROFESSOR: We got a hint
with the problem that said,
n to the power of 1 over log
n is 2, which is order 1.
So for the base case, we always
want them to look like this.
If we don't get a base case,
we write our own base case,
which is if you
plug in a constant,
you're going to get a constant.
And since we're told that
this guy is a constant,
that's a pretty good hint
that we want to get to it.
Let's see how we're
doing on time.
Good.
Ready to move on to
the next problem?
Let's do a fun one.
Some people might remember
it from elementary school,
but this time, we're going to
look at it with our 6.006 eyes.
So suppose you have
m coins, gold coins.
One of them is face.
The fake one is super light
because it's not real gold.
It's something that
looks like gold.
And we have a scale, and
the scale is super accurate.
It can weigh any
coins on either side
and tell us which
side is heavier.
Perfect accuracy, no need
to worry about errors.
I want to find out which
coin is the bad coin.
What is the minimum number
of experiments I have to do?
So there is a strategy, and
we can worry about that later,
but using 6.006, what is the
minimum number of experiments
I have to do?
AUDIENCE: Log N times.
PROFESSOR: Not quite.
So this is what you
think is, and you
can do log n with
binary search, right?
The problem with binary search
is if I put half of my coins
on the left, half of
my coins on the right,
one side is going to
be heavier, right?
So the answers are going
to be this or this,
but I never get this.
I only get one
bit of information
instead of getting one trit.
A trit is a base three digit.
How many bits of
information in a trit?
AUDIENCE: One and a half.
PROFESSOR: Roughly.
AUDIENCE: Log 3.
PROFESSOR: Log 3.
And we know that it's
base 2 because that's
what we use in CS.
So we're discarding a
fractional bit of information
if we're not allowing
for this to happen.
Anyone want to try
something else?
We have to prove
this, by the way.
We have to prove the minimum
that we come up with.
AUDIENCE: You could
just do it coin by coin,
but that would take forever.
PROFESSOR: That's
N. That's worse.
AUDIENCE: How about log base
4 N or something like that?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
to me why we can't just
do binary search?
PROFESSOR: We can.
It's definitely going to
give us the correct answer,
but it's not the minimum
number of weighings
because we're discarding
a possible answer.
So if you do binary
search, you will never
get that the two
sides are equal.
AUDIENCE: Log base 3.
PROFESSOR: Log base
3 would be better
because we have three
choices all the time.
Let's prove that.
So the right answer happens to
be log base 3 of N. Let's see
how we would get it
aside from guessing.
AUDIENCE: So you
divide it into thirds
and compare one third and one
third, and if they're equal,
then the light one is
in the other third.
And if they're not,
[INAUDIBLE] light one.
Then you just keep
dividing by 3.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So that's the strategy.
What if I don't
know the strategy?
How do I do this without
knowing the strategy?
AUDIENCE: What if the number
of coins isn't divisible by 3?
PROFESSOR: Math people.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but then
how do you-- OK, never mind.
AUDIENCE: Just take the two
extra coins and toss them out.
PROFESSOR: If it's
not divisible by 3,
you add fake coins
that are good.
I mean, you use good coins.
But we're not worried
about the strategy.
I want us to think
of a lower bound.
This is a lower bound
for an algorithm, right?
You cannot do better
than log 3 N experiments.
Does the word "lower
bound" ring any bells?
Is there any lecture where
we talked about lower bounds?
So if you sort and you're
using a comparison model,
what's the best you can do?
AUDIENCE: N log N.
PROFESSOR: N log N. Good.
So sorting using CMP, the
comparison model, is N log N.
How did we prove that?
One word.
Well, two words.
Decision trees.
Does anyone remember
what decision trees are?
One person.
AUDIENCE: It's just a
comparison thing, right?
You're like, is it
greater, is it less than,
or is there some
sort of question
you're asking about each key.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
Let's go over that a little bit.
No matter what
your algorithm is,
it's going to weigh
some coins and it's
going to get an
answer from the scale.
And then based on that, it's
going to weigh some other coins
and get some answer
from the scale.
And it will do some
experiments and then
it will give you an answer.
So if you draw a decision
tree, it would look like this.
First, we start
with 0 information.
We weigh some coins.
Based on that, we have
three possible answers--
smaller, equal, greater.
Now, if we're here, we're
going to do another experiment.
Three possible answers.
If we're here, another
experiment, three possible
answers.
If we're here, another
experiment, three possible
answers.
Say we do a third experiment.
One, two, three, one, two,
three, one, two, three, one,
two, three, one, two, three,
one, two, three, one, two,
three, one, two,
three, one, two, three.
And then suppose we stop.
If we stop, we have
to give an answer.
So this is an answer,
this is an answer,
this is an answer, answer,
answer, answer, answer, answer.
So how many answers do
I have at the bottom
if I have three levels?
Here I have three
experiments, so three levels
in the decision tree.
How many answers?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: 3 to the third
because I start three
at the first level, nine at
the second, 27 at the third.
Each time, I multiply by 3.
So if I do three weighings, I
can give at most 27 answers.
If I have more than 27
coins, I can't possibly
decide which one is bad
because say if I have 30 coins,
then I need to be able
to give out 30 answers.
My algorithm has to
have a place where
it says the bad coin is coin
one, coin two, coin three, all
the way to coin 30.
Here I only have 27
possible answers,
so this isn't going to
cut it for 30 coins.
I need to do one more comparison
so that I have a deeper tree.
So suppose I have h
comparisons instead.
How many leaves?
How many possible answers?
AUDIENCE: h to the third.
PROFESSOR: Almost.
AUDIENCE: 3 to the h.
PROFESSOR: 3 to the h.
So 3 multiplied by 3 multiplied
by 3 multiplied by 3 h times,
so 3 to the h.
It's no longer equal to 27.
3 to the h is the number
of possible answers.
This has to be bigger or
equal to N. Otherwise,
the algorithm is incorrect.
So what can we say about h?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: We did all
this without even thinking
of what an algorithm
would look like.
This works for any algorithm.
No matter how smart you are, no
matter how much math you know,
your algorithm is going
to be bound by this.
So the fact that the
answer looks like this
gives you some intuition for
how to solve the problem.
If you want to solve the
problem now and figure out
the strategy, you know
that you have a 3 here.
So if you divide
into 2 every time,
you're not going to
get to the right limit.
So first you do this,
you get a lower bound,
and then you use your
intuition to figure out
what the lower bound means.
In this case, it would mean the
strategy that we heard earlier.
You have to divide
into 3 every time
and then figure out what you
do based on the comparison.
So your answer works
perfectly once we have this.
And also, once we
have this, you know
that your answer is correct
because it's optimal.
You can't do better than that.
Any questions on decision trees?
So lower bounds are a
boring topic in general.
They tell you what you can't do.
They don't tell you anything
useful about what you can do.
In some cases, being able to
reason about a lower bound
gives you a hint
of the solution.
New problem.
Suppose we have a 2D map.
There's a hill, and you take
a satellite picture of it
at night, and you get a picture
with bright pixels and not
bright pixels.
There are numbers showing
how bright your pixels are.
1, 2, 1, 2, 3, 0, 0.
I'm going to draw out an example
so we can use our intuition.
0, 0, 1.
So suppose this is our map.
It's W times H-- W
of what these are,
I think they're columns,
and H of the other ones.
And you want to find a
certain picture inside it.
You want to see how many times
does a certain pattern show up.
Say the pattern is
small w times small h,
and it looks like this.
But this will be the
input to your problem,
so the pattern
might be different.
You can't hard code this in.
And this is useful.
This problem is called
a bunker hill problem.
This is a hill, and
this is a bunker.
You take a picture of the hill.
You want to know
where the bunkers are
so you can bomb them at night so
then you can attack the place.
AUDIENCE: That's awful.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
I'll take that as a compliment
So a nice way of solving this?
AUDIENCE: You could just
go through each row,
and then look for a match
for the first row, and then--
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Is this a match?
That's what you're saying.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We can see that's a match.
PROFESSOR: Is this a match?
Is this a match?
By the way, this is a match.
This is not a match, this is not
a match, this is not a match,
this is not a match.
Now we go down here.
This is not a match,
this is not a match,
so on and so forth.
AUDIENCE: That wasn't
what I was suggesting,
but that's a good idea.
PROFESSOR: Maybe you're
suggesting something smarter,
and I don't want to
let you do something
smarter so that we look at the
brute force approach first.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
I was just saying
take the first row
of your bunker,
and then compare
it to other rows,
and once you hit that, then
check and see if the rest of--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's a bit smarter,
so that's harder
to reason about.
Let's take this one and figure
out the running time of it.
AUDIENCE: Does that mean even
if you know it's not a match,
you keep checking
all nine of them?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Say at the worst case,
you only find out
it's not a match all
the way at the end.
AUDIENCE: Are you trying to look
for all matches or just one?
PROFESSOR: All matches.
AUDIENCE: You're limited to n
squared time almost no matter
what, right?
If you have a small
bunker in a large field,
you have to hit the
small bunker every time.
PROFESSOR: Are you going to
solve the problem for me?
AUDIENCE: Are we trying
to find the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
We're trying to
find out the running
time for the dumb
algorithm first.
Humor me and let's
solve this first,
and then let's get to the
efficient algorithm, OK?
AUDIENCE: Big W minus
small w plus 1 times big H
minus small h plus 1.
AUDIENCE: Where'd
you get plus 1 from?
AUDIENCE: So it's WH?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Well, there's
something missing here.
This is how many positions I
have that I have to look at.
How much time does it take
to compare the small images?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This is smaller than
wh, which is the input size,
so it's scary if you have an
algorithm that runs faster
than the input size
because it means
you're not looking
at all the input.
So this is definitely
bigger than the input size
once we add the w times h here.
Don't forget this guy.
This is the naive algorithm, and
if we discard the small order
factors, we get that
this is order of WHwh.
How can you do better?
You have the answer, right?
Let's let everyone else
think for a minute,
and then you can give me
the answer if you want,
or someone else can
give me the answer.
I guess you should because
you thought of it first.
Any ideas?
So you're thinking about
the input size, right?
Someone was thinking
about the input size.
So the input size
is W times H, right?
So if I have an algorithm
that's W times H,
that's optimal because it
has to look at all the input.
Well, we're going to
have an algorithm that's
W times H, so with
that out of the way,
does that inspire anyone
as to what the solution is?
AUDIENCE: Do that thing
that I was saying,
just take the first row, but
then you still have a W term.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So let's make it better.
It is the correct intuition.
Now try to use a trick we
learned in lecture to make that
faster.
AUDIENCE: Just use
the top left corner
instead of the whole row.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we could use the
top left corner,
and if the top left
corner doesn't match,
then we don't have
to check for matches.
So this works for
reasonably random data.
As long as we don't have
a lot of false positives,
we're going to run fast.
Now, the top corner of
this one, if the map
has a lot of 1's and then some
2's sprinkled all over it,
most of the time, we'll have
to go through the whole image
so we're going to have a
lot of false positives.
How do we make our false
positive rate go down?
AUDIENCE: Looks kind of
like a rolling hash problem.
PROFESSOR: Looks like a
rolling hash problem, exactly.
Let's see if we can
use rolling hashes.
AUDIENCE: But then you
still have that lowercase w
term, though.
PROFESSOR: How do
we get rid of it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't it be w?
I mean the running time if we
were just going through one row
would be big W minus
little w, times--
PROFESSOR: So where's
your rolling hash?
AUDIENCE: I guess you can use
the entire thing as a hash,
too.
That would kind of work.
PROFESSOR: So we want a
hash for the whole thing.
Instead of using this as the
hash, we want a smarter hash.
AUDIENCE: It's the
entire thing, and then
as you move to the right, you
can add those and subtract,
and compare that with the hash.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we'd have a rolling hash
that has everything in here,
and then as I move to the
right, I add these guys
and I remove these guys.
This is big W times big
H, roughly, times small h
because every time
I move to the right,
I have to do order h work.
So I'm down from this
thing to order of WHh,
So it's better.
It's one step forward.
Now, let's make
this even faster.
What if I could do this in
order 1 instead of order h?
How would I do this in order 1?
AUDIENCE: You'd have to
compress all the rows,
and then take the
hash of each column.
PROFESSOR: How would
we compress them?
AUDIENCE: Take the
hash of the column.
PROFESSOR: You want
to compress the rows?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
You divide it--
PROFESSOR: Let's not
compress the rows.
AUDIENCE: You could
take just your bunker,
and then figure out the
hashes of the three columns,
and just run through like that.
You'd still have to access
each of those items.
I don't really see
how it's faster.
I guess it's less, though.
It's less.
Maybe it's only 1.
AUDIENCE: So do you want to hash
each little column [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So we're going
to hash all these guys,
and then we're going to
have hashes for them,
and we're going to do
the regular Rabin-Karp
for the hashes.
Now, what happens
when I go down?
PROFESSOR: You have to
recompute everything.
PROFESSOR: Let's do better
than recompute everything.
AUDIENCE: Do you want
to [INAUDIBLE] downward
on each column?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Rolling hash.
I want to make this faster,
so I have big W hashes.
They're all little h inside.
Here, I have to compute
them brute force.
I can't do anything better.
But when I go from
here to here, there's
only one element going out
and one element going in.
Same for all these guys.
Let's not make the picture
uglier than it needs to be.
So I have big W rolling hashes.
They're vertical rolling hashes.
And then the rolling hashes
hash columns, so my the sliding
window that I have is
little w rolling hashes.
Each rolling hash is little h in
size, so it's a hash of hashes.
It's nested hashes.
And then when I go
down, I only have
to roll down each of
the rolling hashes by 1,
so that's constant time.
So to go from here to here, to
the slide the window one down,
I have to roll this hash
down, roll this one,
this one, this one, this one,
this one, and all of them
roll down in constant time.
So when I'm adding a column
to the hash, say I'm here
and I want to go here,
I roll down this hash
and I have the answer.
It's order 1.
I'm adding it in order 1.
Does this make sense?
AUDIENCE: It's tricky.
PROFESSOR: But it's
not too bad, right?
AUDIENCE: You just need to do
the vertical roll first, right?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
To have the simplest
possible code,
you start with big W rolling
hashes, do 1D Rabin-Karp,
you roll everything
down, 1D Rabin-Karp,
and keep doing that.
OK What's the running
time for this?
AUDIENCE: WH.
PROFESSOR: WH.
AUDIENCE: Does this one have a
space complexity about W, then,
because [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So my memory requirement
went up to 4W.
Is everyone happy with this?
It's one of the few cases where
an approach for solving a 1D
problem generalizes to 2D.
In most problems, you have to
rethink the whole situation.
Let's do a hard problem.
Enough with the easy ones.
Two lists, roughly size N,
and they're both sorted.
Let me fill them out
with random numbers.
5, 13, 22, 43, 56, 62, 81,
86, 87, 2, 3, 7, 9, 15, 19,
24, 28, 32.
So I have these lists.
Let's be generous and say that
all the numbers are different.
They're sorted.
I want to find the nth number,
so the number with rank n,
out of both lists
as fast as possible.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
it just be index?
PROFESSOR: So the thing is
if, for example, n is 1,
then it's this.
This is the second number.
This is the third.
So if you take the lists
and you combine them,
then I want the
result out of that.
AUDIENCE: Let's do merge
sort and the combined
[INAUDIBLE] index, right?
PROFESSOR: Full
merge sort, N log N?
No.
AUDIENCE: It's already
sorted, though.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what do we do?
AUDIENCE: We just do merge.
That's just order N.
PROFESSOR: So merge.
AUDIENCE: Merge [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So merge and then index
is the first approach,
which is order N. Then you
said run the merge algorithm,
but stop when you get to
the little nth element,
so that's a little bit
better and we don't have
to produce an array so the space
complexity is down to order 1,
right?
Now let's do--
AUDIENCE: Logarighmic times n.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
This is linear.
We have to get to logarithms.
How do we get to logarithms?
AUDIENCE: Do a
modified binary search.
AUDIENCE: What if you
first looked at-- actually,
I don't know what
I'm going to say.
PROFESSOR: Anyone else?
So modified binary search.
Do you know the full
answer, or do you
want to start looking
at the solution?
AUDIENCE: I have an
idea [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let's see
how it would work.
AUDIENCE: So if we take
the n over second element
on each row, the
one that is lower,
that's at least the n
over second element,
and the one that's higher--
PROFESSOR: So let's say
this is our N1 and N2,
and they're both
order N initially.
So this is N2 over 2
if this is smaller.
AUDIENCE: The lower
one is at least
the N over second
element since everything
before it is less than
N. Does that make sense?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is N over 2
are greater, right?
This guy.
AUDIENCE: We also know
that the element above it
is at most the nth element
because it's greater than--
PROFESSOR: So it's
at most N1 plus N2
because that's how
many you have in total,
and the one on the top, you
know that these ones are
bigger than h, right?
But you don't know
anything about these ones,
so it's minus N1 over 2.
So it's at most N1 over 2
plus N2, the top element.
AUDIENCE: So then we can take
the element three quarters
of the way through N2 and
one quarter of the way
through N1 to do
more [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Let's see what
happens in each case.
So if little n is
here, then you divide.
So if n is smaller than this,
then you chop them up here
and you've divided
the problem into half.
You're good.
If it's bigger than
this other number here,
you've chopped the problem
up and you're here.
You're good.
Now, the hard case seems
to be when it's in between.
So what do we do then?
AUDIENCE: Aren't those
two numbers the same?
AUDIENCE: If it's between,
take the upper half
of the bottom one and the lower
half of the upper one, right?
If it's between 15 and 43,
then you take everything
in the upper half of N2 and
you take the lower half of N1.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
you should always
be taking the upper half
of one and the lower
half of the other in this case.
PROFESSOR: Really?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
N2, 15 is at least
the nth over 2 element.
I think we're using three
n's at the same time.
AUDIENCE: Are you using
the little n or the big N?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
[INAUDIBLE] is element
and the lists are called N
and this is confusing.
Can we rename the nth
element to something
like m or some
other useful number?
The kth element, OK.
So the 15 at least the
kth over 2 element,
so it can't be anything
on the left half of the--
PROFESSOR: k over 2?
Why k over 2?
This list is size N.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I didn't pick the
elements at N over 2.
I picked the
elements at k over 2.
PROFESSOR: Why would I do that?
If N1 is greater than k, then
I chop off the end of the list,
right?
If N2 is bigger than k, then
I chop off the end of the list
completely.
If this list is sorted and
I want the third element,
I know that these
are not the answer.
No matter what's down here,
these are not the answer.
So I know for sure that k is
going to be bigger than N1, N2.
So instead of going there,
let's go at k over 2.
And here, let's go for k over 2.
Now this one looks
a bit nastier.
N1 plus N2 stays
what it was before.
AUDIENCE: On the list where you
got the element that was lower,
you know that everything to
the left of it is less than k
over 2.
The element number is
lower than k over 2,
so we're not using anything
to the left of the 15.
You can kill that
section for us.
PROFESSOR: OK, so we can kill
it, but then what's the rank?
When I recurse, how
am I going to know
the rank that I'm looking for?
AUDIENCE: k minus
what you killed.
AUDIENCE: You can
save the branches.
PROFESSOR: So you want
to kill this guy, right?
So you want to
kill these numbers.
But here I have
k over 2 numbers,
and here I have
k over 2 numbers.
How do I know that it's
not somewhere here?
AUDIENCE: How do you know that
what's not somewhere there?
AUDIENCE: You compare
15 and 43, right?
And then you see
that 43 is bigger,
and you see 15 is smaller, so
then you would go to, I guess,
k over 4 index in N1,
and 3k over 4 in N2.
AUDIENCE: When you
recurse, you said
that you've killed
k over 2 elements.
AUDIENCE: But you can also kill
everything to the right of 43.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
You can kill everything
to the right of 43
since it can't be any
of those elements,
and you can kill everything
to the left of 15.
And then you repeat the
algorithm again with the lists
you didn't kill, except you
also put in a term of we've
already covered k
over 2 elements.
PROFESSOR: So we want the
element with the rank k over 4
over these lists.
So I know for sure that what
I have is either k over 2
or less than k over 2, right?
So this is less than
k over 2, and then I'm
looking for a rank of k over 4.
That seems to work.
How does the running time look?
AUDIENCE: It should
be O of log k.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's log [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So log
k, log N1 plus N2.
Are these different?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: If k is
1, the algorithm
should only recurse once,
even if N is 20 million.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: But if k is 20
million and the list lengths are
two million long, it'll take
approximately those lengths
to run.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what gets reduced, aside from
the list size, k gets reduced.
k seems to define the input
size for the next iteration
because I'll have at least
k over 2 elements in one
of these buckets.
So it sounds like
it should be log k.
k is bigger than N1, N2, but
it should hopefully be smaller
than the sum because otherwise,
why am I doing the problem?
So this is definitely
order of N1 plus N2.
So this is a bound.
This is a slightly
tighter bound.
We have a different
solution to the problem.
All the possible solutions
are hard to argue.
They all come down to
something like this.
The one that we have
requires you to use-- you
have two indices, and you know
that the sum of the indices
is k, and you do binary
search on the top
and adjust the
index on the bottom
to keep the constraint that the
sum of the two indices in N.
And you can look at that in the
notes that we're going to post.
Are you guys tired?
Do you want to look at one
more thing, or are we done?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let's look at
something reasonably easy.
You guys can read
this on your own.
I'm not going to
bore you with that.
So suppose we have
some functions,
and we want to
order them according
to their asymptotic growth rate.
Do people remember how
to do this from Pset one?
So the idea is that you take
each function, you simplify it,
and then you sort them.
So let's have a couple of simple
ones and then some hard ones,
and we're going to
stop in five minutes.
What's this?
AUDIENCE: n to the fourth.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's see.
n choose 3.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, very good.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Something about choose
is n times n minus 1 times
n minus 2.
AUDIENCE: It's n factorial
over n minus 2 factorial.
PROFESSOR: This comes out
to be roughly n cubed.
Cool.
How about n plus log
to the fourth of n?
AUDIENCE: N.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So even if I have a
polynomial in a logarithm,
it's still dominated by pure n.
Now, suppose we want to
order these guys together
with-- which one doesn't
look boring at all?
n to the log n and 2 to the n.
Let's sort them.
Which one's the smallest?
Which one's the biggest?
AUDIENCE: 2 to the n is bigger.
PROFESSOR: Let's start
with the smallest ones,
because I think
that will be easy.
So which one's the absolute
smallest out of all these guys?
AUDIENCE: n.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Then?
AUDIENCE: n to the third.
PROFESSOR: Cubed and fourth.
So we have to
compare these guys.
How do we compare them?
n to the power of log n
and 2 to the n something.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Take the logs.
So when we have something
confusing with exponentials,
take the logs and
see what we get.
Logs are monotonic, so
if you take the logs,
you'll have the same
relationship afterwards.
So log of this is log of
n to the power of log n,
so it's log n times
log n, so it's log 2 n.
Log of 2 to the n is n.
Which one's bigger?
AUDIENCE: n.
PROFESSOR: All right.
And we're not going
to solve this,
but how would you go
about solving this guy?
What do you do to it?
AUDIENCE: Sterling.
PROFESSOR: Sterling, yep.
You do Sterling, you
go through the numbers,
and you figure out the answer.
And then if you have
to do logarithms,
you use logarithms
to figure out where
it belongs among these guys.
AUDIENCE: What's Sterling?
AUDIENCE: Sterling's formula.
It's that gross thing
that was on the board
before we came in here.
PROFESSOR: So Sterling says
that n factorial is ugly.
2 pi n here times n over
e to the power of n.
So what's this binomial?
What's the formula for it?
OK, formula for n choose k.
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: It's n times 1
over 2 factorial times n
minus k factorial.
PROFESSOR: In this
case, it's n factorial
over n over 2 factorial raised
to the power of 2, right?
And then we chug through the
math and get to some answer.
All right?